thank you so much Bob and it's my
pleasure now to introduce function our
next speaker so far is the James and
Patricia
Poitras professor of Neuroscience at MIT
and here at the McGovern Institute and
he's also a core member of the Broad
Institute and an associate professor in
the department's of brain and cognitive
sciences as well as biological
engineering
he got obtained his PhD in Calder
theroths lab and has received just
numerous awards and accolades for his
groundbreaking research and he was even
recently selected as an HHMI
investigator Fung discovers and develops
CRISPR tools and played an
extraordinarily important role in
bringing the gene editing field to a
point where diagnosing and treating
diseases through gene therapy has become
a realistic proposition I'm very excited
to hear his talk the title of which is
advances in genome editing good morning
it's a great pleasure to be here
I I instituted in 2011 and I remember
the first time that I met with Pat was
during one of the first McGovern
Halloween parties and and and talking
about I will talk about China and his
experiences and developing businesses
and publishing in China but one thing
that really made a huge impression on me
was that he was very curious and he
really wanted to understand and the
science and and know what was happening
that I was going to work on and and so
Pat I'm gonna give you an update what
we'll be working on and so we'll get the
science started so one of the things
that has motivated our work has been the
completion of human genome by sequencing
the genome of now hundreds of thousands
of individuals many different genetic
variants have been identified and some
of these variants are associated with
disease in some of these variants are
associated with reduced risk for disease
and so one of the tantalizing thought is
if we can edit DNA in cells then we'll
be able to much more effectively
understand the function of these
different variants but also potentially
use some of these knowledge to be able
develop new treatments for disease so
over the past almost nine years we've
been working on developing tools based
on a micro be immune system called
CRISPR and there are a number of
different proteins found in these CRISPR
immune systems that can be developed to
be able to wholly into specific
sequences in our DNA and then be able to
make specific changes so that we can
study genetic variants or potentially
develop an therapeutics there are two
ways that the genome editing systems are
used the first is using the RNA guided
nucleases examples of these include cast
9 to be able to target specific
locations in the genome and to be able
to either knock genes out or to
stimulate recombination new sequences
into the DNA the second way to apply
this is by inactivating the nucleus of
these proteins to turn them into RNA
guided DNA binding proteins and these
actors homing devices that will allow
you to bring a number of different
effector molecules to different genomic
loci you can turn genes on by bringing a
transcriptional activator you can turn
genes off by bringing histone remodelers
to be able to close the chromatin and
you can also image how DNA work or be
able to modify DNA bases using the
eminences and so these are the two main
ways through which this RNA guided DNA
binding assistant has allowed
researchers to develop a number of
different tools for probing and also to
understand biology so rather than
talking to you about Casner i wanted to
talk you talk to you about what's beyond
cast night to think about that take a
look at this picture that's on the left
side it shows the number of different
CRISPR systems that that were identified
back in the year 2011 and so if you look
at each one of these
clusters of proteins these are different
types of crisper systems and cast 9 is
this system that's not here is much
simpler than all the other quiz
persistent because it uses the least
number of proteins but what this picture
really highlight is that there's
enormous diversity in CRISPR systems and
so one question that we asked was that
besides caste 9 are there other
relatively simple CRISPR systems that
would lend themselves to development as
interesting useful technologies so if we
look at these diverse systems we can
group them into two different classes
they're what's called the class one
CRISPR systems which are ones that use
multiple proteins that work together to
mediate the the recognition also
destruction of invading viruses in
bacterial cells and then cash 9 belongs
to class 2 at the time cash cash Nile
was the only class 2 system that was
known it's the one thing that we wanted
to to figure out is are there other
class 2 systems that haven't yet been
discovered from the microbial diversity
and so using computational approaches to
mine new CRISPR sequences that haven't
yet been you know experimentally studied
we found that there are two new CRISPR
systems that extend beyond caste night
so so there's the cassadine based CRISPR
system which we have developed where for
gene editing applications but then
there's also a second also DNA targeting
CRISPR system characterized by a protein
called cash twelve we've also developed
this for for gene editing as well and in
many ways it is much more specific than
some of the cast lines that we developed
so for therapeutic applications it has a
particular advantages the third system
is a family characterized by a protein
called caste 13 and these are RNA gyda r
n8 hardening enzymes and rather than
target DNA these allowed us to develop a
whole new set of tools to be able to
address a different set of important
molecules or within cells and so today I
want to tell you a little bit about
13 and the various applications that
would have developed using this for
Diagnostics and also for RNA editing
applications so this is what we know to
date but of course as we sequence more
and more organisms in profile more
corners of the world it's very possible
that they're going to be many other
CRISPR systems and and and many of them
will be potentially useful for
developing new applications as well so
our innate targeting of transfer team
was first sort of hypothesize based on
analysis if the sequences forecaster
team so if you look at a primary
sequence in protein you'll find two very
well conserved motifs that are called
heppen motifs and these are usually
found in proteins that cut RNA or in
toxins and that are found in bacteria
and so the first thing we did is we took
the whole CRISPR cast Thirteen's system
from one back to bacteria called
laboratory here shocky this is a very
difficult to work with organism there so
the first thing we did is to put into
e.coli so that we can experiment and
manipulate it but we RNA sequencing and
we found that not only are the proteins
expressed but also the Christopher RNA
is expressed and that is modified into
this short mature forms of guide RNAs
that that tells us that this system is
most likely a functional after
transplantation in to be polite so then
we've found that castrating can target
RNA that used as a guide RNA to
recognize RNA and then and then degrade
it but what's really interesting is that
it has a second form of RNAs activity
and this is what we call collateral or
any activity so this is a way that
clattering could be works imagine this
experiment here you have a guide RNA and
also a piece of RNA and that's not
recognizable by the guy so there's no
complementarity between the guide and
this target if you're adding cancer teen
then there's no cleavage of this
molecule this makes sense because
there's no recognition no cleavage but
what happens if you have both the target
RNA as well as a piece of collateral
learning what we found is that now if
you add in caster teen not only is the
target RNA cleave
in two different fragments but this
non-target are they all so clean and so
let's address that the active or the
recognition event bike has routine with
the target RNA switches cast routine
into a constituent in the active state
so you can go and cut other RNA
molecules as well in this cell so what
is this good for one of the things that
we took advantage of this property is to
develop Diagnostics applications
especially for infections like virus
infections Ebola Zika or bacterial
pathogens it's important to have easy
inexpensive and also rapid Diagnostics
tests so that that these diseases
diseases can be diagnosed accurately
right away and so you can take advantage
this collateral rnase activity to
develop a diagnostic system and so this
is a way it works if we take human urine
saliva or blood plasma or even a cheek
swab we can extract nucleic acid from
these biological samples by incubating
these biological samples with either the
cast with the castor team protein a
guide RNA has been programmed to
recognize the the virus that were trying
to detect in this example and showing
Zika virus we can also mix in a second
reporter RNA that's basically a bio tiny
and also a formality called fam better
together
if castrati recognizes the Zika virus
RNA then it will activate the nucleus
activity and go and cleave this reporter
and it will unlock the fam away from
from the biotin they'll be separated and
so what he end up is this this property
allows us to then develop a paper strip
based lateral flow test and and this is
the way this works so if the virus is
not present then the reporter RNA will
be intact and that means biotin and fam
will be tethered together
so if you flow they sound a lot of
lateral flow strip what you find is that
the sample will flow in this direction
and everything will get captured by the
a burden a binding light and that's
because biotin will get captured there
and then Sam is still tethered a virus
RNA if the virus is present then when
you flow this biotin will get bound by
streptavidin
but fam will keep him flowing because he
is now being cleaved off if the biotin
molecule and so then it will get
captured by the antibody capture light
and so you will see two lines showing
you up rather than one line and this
provides a very easy color matching
based readout and to tell you whether or
not the infections molecules are our
present and sin those these are example
images of of a lot of flow based tests
and so by supplying Zika containing
samples at various concentrations we
found that you can quite reliably detect
at about 200 at the molar sensitivity
and this is about 100 molecules of virus
per microliter of the biological
specimen and so this is a good
sensitivity range to be able to detect
and relatively or early stages in a
virus infection so this is for detecting
infections but then there also ways to
be able to use a cancer gene in a more
therapeutic relevant modality and that's
my developing ways to edit the RNA so
one of the application that would really
want to develop is to be able to change
sequences in in neurons but neurons are
post mitotic and so by using himangshu
combination neurons it's proven to be
very efficient because the homogeneous
recombination machineries are not
expressed at a very active levels in
neurons so BM DNA RNA provides an
alternative solution to be able to make
precise changes in neurons and so some
of the enzymes that Nature has evolved
include proteins that can convert the
Dena scenes into innocence and so in the
scenes are read by the stress that the
translational machinery is a guanosine
so if you can convert a - I don't even
effectively and altered the way that a
mRNA can be interpreted by the cell and
so to to turn cancer into RNA editing
system
we we took the wild-type hand routine
and then we modified it we get got rid
of the nucleus domi instead it only
binds to RNA and it doesn't cleave and
so by using this we can tether a dart
domains to target a specific mRNA and
and so we can program this Adar cancer
gene fusion to recognize a specific mRNA
by designing a guide RNA that
complements the RNA that we're trying to
edit and so one of the really unique
properties about Adar is that edits
Idina scenes that are mismatched in the
RNA duplex and so that gives us the
ability to control specifically which
adenosine is edited on the target RNA
and and so the way we do this is we
design a guide and then for the base
that's opposite of the a that wanted the
M&A we change it to a cytosine so that
is mismatched and this allows us to then
target the mRNA and the form a bubble
and exactly the base for the emanation
and then a dart will act on this bubble
and then convert this adenosine to
inosine and the alternative the way that
this mRNA can be translated so this is a
more detailed version of how we would go
about designing it so note notice that
this is the target RNA and then there
are motor poet dinner scenes within the
binding region by this guide RNA but we
can specify the deamination this this
very specific dinner scene by using a
single base for mismatch to be able to
direct it so this is just some example
data showing that we can indeed control
and achieve pretty specific and also
accurate editing this is with on the
left side this is with the first version
of the repair system so you can see that
we get pretty good the emanation at the
targeted base but there's also quite a
bit of off target activity and then by
tweaking the affinity of of Adar for the
target RNA were then able to engineer a
second version called repair v2 that's
much more specific so now we can
entirely localize the editing event to
the targeted base and get rid of the
other I'll target editing
kiddies so web began to apply this in a
neurological context so we were able to
engineer castle routine so that's small
enough that we can package it along with
a tower and the guide RNA into a single
ad vector and they use this to deliver
into neurons and so we targeted one of
the housekeeping genes and we found that
we can get fairly good levels of editing
this is in primary neuron culture and we
can get about close to 40 percent
editing for for target based in the
target RNA and so so we'll continue to
do this and we're now trying to apply
this in a couple of mouse models
neurological disease to see can we use
RNA editing as a way to reverse the
disease phenotype we're continuing to
develop RNA editing into a more broad
toolbox and so one of the things we have
been focused on is to expand the
repertoire of base changes that working
achieve in in neurons and so the second
editor that we've been developing
converse cytosines into yourselves and
this has a couple of very unique
applications one of them is to ice
expand the number of genetic mutations
that we can we can correct but a second
is that we can transiently
use the system to be able to alter the
signaling of molecules such as beta
catenin and then be able to drive a
proliferation in them proliferative
tissues and in so for example by making
changes such as s33 f we can transient
acne beta catenin and then get it to
trigger proliferation in the eye or in
the liver or or in the in a year in the
way we did this is rather than taking a
natural sign in via Munez which don't
have single base specificity we can use
a base system to evolve a dart so that
it becomes AC dark so it changes c and
to yourself and so by by performing
saturated saturation mutagenesis
followed by selection and validation in
mammalian cells we found that we can
indeed get a dart to the M&A cytosines
and and so these are some of the the
progress that we have made so far
this is up to about version 8 of the the
rescue system for for CTU editing and
and we went from really no activity now
to about 40% activity in the in the
target cytosine base and so we're
continuing to work on this and and we
are really excited to also develop this
into an into a robust tool with with
potential therapeutic applications so
we're continuing to work on also
increasing the specificity and also the
efficiency and then and then hopefully
the next time I can tell you more about
our work on on the testing of using
animal models trying to see if we can
reverse neurological disease phenotypes
so one of the things that were really
excited to work on for the for the next
phase is to see can we discover other
forms of novel programmable systems if
you think about caste 9 or antibodies
and this particular form antibody found
in jawless vertebrates called vor and
also the the DNA binding domain tail
these are all forms of defense systems
that Nature has evolved to protect
against and then rapidly changing in
number of pathogens and so one question
is are there other systems that Nature
has evolved in or continuing to use
computational methods now to see can we
discover other forms of adaptive immune
systems from the microbial world and to
then develop other programmable
technologies and so here's just one
example of an interesting protein that
we found this is by looking for
repetitive sequences that have undergone
rapid diversification and so if you look
at this particular one from
streptococcus it carries a very well
conserved IgA Proteus like domain but
then on the under 5 prime end on the
interim there are these highly
repetitive regions similar to the repeat
domains that you will find at AO protein
and if you analyze each one of these
repeats you'll find that they are
largely identical except they carry
specific regions that have hyper
variation and so we're working on this
system we're hypothesizing that this
this is likely imputed
a programmable protein protease system
so if we can figure out what we
programmed this target variety proteins
and then we may have ways to to use this
for for other therapeutic applications
maybe for for getting rid of a beta and
plaques or or alpha-synuclein
and many other different proteins so
that's truly just to highlight the fact
that we have only scratched the surface
this is only the tip of iceberg
so as of last year over 140,000 by 3
genomes having a sequence and if you
look at meta genomic sequences that
amount of data multiplies by another
order order of magnitude and so what
this means is that there are a lot of
interesting systems that await discovery
and all of them will be interesting and
some of them will undoubtedly be be
useful as well
so next time I hope that give you that
update that finally I want to
acknowledge my my team at McGovern and
the building Institute our collaborators
and also the funding agencies that have
made our work possible so thank you very
much for your entries Network we have
time for a couple of questions questions
so specific
yeah this is really good question so one
application is to use castor 13 to
target the destruction of mRNA and and
knock down the protein so we found that
in eukaryotic cells a million cells it's
actually quite specific so then she
served on Wyatt sequencing and in a high
depth and we find that for the transfers
are targeting or really only just
knocking in that transcript well then
also comparison with shRNA we find that
shRNA would have maybe dozens - maybe a
hundred off target sites with cancer
teen away we don't see that so very
interesting talk so I'm just wondering
so you've got a forty percent efficiency
for your AV vector in the neurons right
so in terms of reversing the entities
model phenotype how can how can control
the specificity or how can control which
forty percent you target in terms of
reversing the phenotypes over certain
models yes - so maybe can you repeat I'm
not quite sure what you mean by control
which forty percent so the efficiency
you using your system about forty
percent right test in the decision you
don't know culture yes right so in terms
of for in vivo application so can you
control the you know which population
you can reverse in terms of reversing
the phenotype of certain neurological
diseases sure yeah thank you for the
question so the question is in the brain
there are many many different cell types
how do we control which cell type to
edit and can we get achieve enough edit
in the cell type that that makes that
that would that won't matter so the way
that were delivery is using AAV and
there are a few different ways that we
can eliminate the expression of this to
the cells that we want to modify
now this can be done either using cell
type-specific promoters or by selecting
variants of a be that may have some
specificity for the cell types of
interest and so what we found in the
dissociate experiment is that if we are
the associate neurons we can achieve on
average 40% editing and that's the mass
of the cells within that experimental
sample so if we deliver into neurons if
AV is restricted to to be expressed in a
specific cell population then within all
the a be trans to cells I think we'll be
able to get sort of 40% or maybe even
higher editing and then specifically how
much editing is necessary to have a
therapeutic outcome that will most
likely depend on the protein that were
trying to fix some proteins don't have
to be ever higher levels especially
catalytic enzymes whereas other
structural proteins will probably need
to be fixed at a fairly high level
I I'm this is a totally naive question
but in terms of potentially using this
these sorts of technologies and
understand this that's a very broad
question the CRISPR technologies are the
antibody technologies you were talking
about you know what are the I don't know
where the technology is in terms of you
know actually using this sort of thing
for therapy so in other words what I'm
thinking mostly about is how you would
deliver these things and whether they'd
be biologically available particularly
in the brain so maybe let's take it in
this direction you know are there
significant obstacles to say injecting
these kind of things into a blood and
then having them access the brain right
that's a very good question so so CRISPR
CRISPR technology has gone through many
iterations and so now it's already being
tested in the clinic and are broadly
speaking two ways to develop this as a
therapeutic one is through ex vivo
editing where you take cells for example
from the blood system out of the patient
and modify in a petri dish and then put
it back to the patient this can be done
quite efficiently using electroporation
or or transient transfection of mrna the
second way to deliver is to directly
injecting in vivo and this has been done
using viruses so av viral vectors to
deliver into specific tissues or
possibly in the near future using Libby
nanoparticles to deliver mRNA for for
these molecules when one human trial has
already begun in in the Western
Hemisphere and that's for beta
thalassemia is using ex vivo therapeutic
delivery and then and then party later
this year another vivo approach will
start this is for treating a blindness
disorder by using AV directing injection
into the eye
thank you for your questions and thank
you so much fun
so a coffee break now this coffee
outside and we'll reconvene at 10:55
thank you
[Applause]